[Music]
I say what I have been lucky enough to
get the opportunity to come to
Philadelphia for a few days to film with
my wack filming another conference boom
but I do get at least one day to explore
Philadelphia and it's Christmas as well
I mean it's December everything's old
it's up everything's all Christmasy and
I'm just feeling so ah like so happy at
the moment so I'm just excited to be in
another continent in America and
Philadelphia I've never been here before
so I figured why not take you with me
you can see what we can see do what we
can do
we'll go on this little little journey
together cuz I think you guys know by
now that I quite enjoy traveling it's
important to do because we're only hit
once and I want to make the most of it I
want to see whatever I can see I want to
take hold of every opportunity I can I
can grasp and make the very most of it
and if I can share that with you even
better so yeah enjoy free Delphia with
me first things first though I need to
show you around my hotel room because it
is a freaking king-size hotel room all
for myself I wonder what this is crazy I
mean just look at this bed just look
this bad I'm good I'm gonna do some
salts in bed somersaults in the color of
seating area so if you can't see it very
well I have already got many lights on
because I'm getting ready for bed this
was very exciting to me I'm gonna have
real coffee in the morning guys maybe if
you're lucky you'll see me through to my
morning coffee yeah there's a wardrobe
it hola ironing board I don't iron so
I'm probably going to use that another
little window mirror not a window it's a
mirror it's late guys I wish that for
ages it's probably like 3 o'clock in the
morning in my time
oh yeah a toilet everything a girl could
mean I'm probably a bit more because you
know you don't really need as much as we
usually have that's a little something
for you to think about anyway I'm off to
bed
don't laugh on my hair don't do it
but will you people who ask me how do
you get your hair so curly this is it
natural I kind of tame it so good
morning I am in Philadelphia I'm trying
to figure out what did you say I knew I
need a coffee first of all but then I
love us here to the hotel pool or just
go straight outside then go to the
market that is like lychee right by the
hotel I mean the pool would be nice hmm
let me think
[Music]
major change of plan guys so when I got
out of bed I was like oh what's that
it's something moving yes yes look at
this little critter yeah so I had a
bedbug in my bag I'm in my bag I had a
bed bug in my bed and I ain't my face it
ate my cheek so now I'm gonna go
downstairs let the people know about my
bedbug I might get moved so I'm trying
to make the most out of this big room
I've just been doing some handstands or
attempting to because you know make the
most of what you got why you got it um
so yeah I'll keep you updated on that
situation not the best start of the day
but we were okay okay hi guys
new new room new place yeah I have
bedbugs that was a great experience um
but you know I don't know it kind of
made me think I was like how how do you
act in that situation because I know a
lot of people would expect something
like um it's talking to my mom and she
was like maybe they'll put you in a
better room but I was already in the
king room and I was like you know what I
don't care as long as I get a room
without bed bugs
I don't mind and the manager came and he
was like oh one of the managers I don't
know I think so he's like I'm so sorry
please this isn't because we're I'm
clean and I was like I get it like
bedbugs it's a thing that happens and
sure maybe I could have had gold because
it's midday now and I know I need to
shower because of the bedbug situation
but I'm so freakin hungry and I haven't
eaten yet so maybe I could have like
been like hey can you bring me some food
but I'm just I'm just not like a person
I just can't do it so they do something
about the situation then it's okay and
so I have got this new room it's a
normal sized room oh hi back it's a
normal sized room let me show you around
I never showed you the outside of the
king-size room but I actually prefer
this I know was just buildings hear me
out you can see the Christmas tree you
see and look at this wonderful painting
it's really nice I like it I prefer like
rustic things I guess my perfect holiday
would be a cabin in the woods so I ain't
going complain and I had one night in
the kingslayer's room I just really hope
that these bedbugs have not stayed with
me that's the only thing I'm worried
about so I'm gonna have to shower and
then I'll sort out food and everything
maybe it won't get as much done in
Philadelphia today as I was hoping to
but oh well I'm still gonna block this
experience with you it's like holiday
gone wrong
yes so yeah this is the room I've got
now it's it's very simple it's very
sweet it's still nice way and then look
I mean the bathroom is always my
favorite part of any hotel anyway I'm
gonna like stop showing you the hotel
room and try and get out and about I
just need to sort myself out or I've got
bite on my cheek also I am going into
that swimming pool at some point today
so I'll try and show you as much as I
can after my hectic morning there's
nothing I can think better than going
into this gorgeous pool and it's
completely empty there's no one here so
I'm gonna have an amazing time in this
pool
[Music]
hi okay so I am out of the pool now and
that was so good just to swim on my own
and I am naked I think it's because I
haven't eaten yet and it is like 1:00 in
the afternoon I think so I need to go
and eat but you know what I don't think
I'm gonna push myself today because I
have been ill all week it was like a big
deadline weekend in a university and
iced I'm working tomorrow but this is my
only day in Philadelphia that I get to
myself I've never been here before so I
want to go out and have a walk around
and maybe look for some presents for my
friends because I mean it's Christmas
and yeah it gets some coffee and to the
food food is needed so that is the plan
I'm just gonna get my clothes from the
clothes cleaning place but cuz I was
wearing them to bed
with bedbugs so that that's the thing
but as soon as I get them I'm out even
if it's just for an hour I'm getting out
[Music]
Hey so I am back um I have a little walk
around got some Christmas presents you
don't one thing that I realize I mean I
haven't traveled that far that's that
many places but it's all kinda like the
same like this German markets in England
there's German markets here and I went
to Germany probably is good this German
and markets there but one thing that I
really love about Philadelphia is how
how friendly everyone is everyone is
really really friendly it's really nice
because I find coming from look around
London area people may be a bit
standoffish but here everyone's opening
the doors at all saying thank you and
sorry and the amount of times that I
would kind of almost bump into someone
and they would be the one to say like oh
sorry there you go I don't know it's
just very nice here and people just seem
very outgoing and forward and I guess
that's an American for you I mean that's
what I've always known Americans to be
like stereotypically very confident very
outgoing and a lot of people seem like
that here I mean they're not scared to
put on a Santa outfit and dance around
or just talk to people you know say good
morning and good afternoon and how are
you doing in stuff it's it's actually
really really nice
but anyway it's something called a sushi
burrito which I have heard a lot of help
thanks um I'm excited because I love
sushi oh my gosh it's pretty nude
it's like subway in a sense that you get
to choose what's inside the sushi
burrito and yeah so I got tofu because
vegetarian and all but
wasn't that there's like pickled ginger
EDA mama beans in the mama beans pickled
carrots tofu lettuce or just all the
good stuff wrapped in beans the beans
and rice this has turned into one of
those foodie channels now I'm just so
frickin excited to either okay I can't
wait anymore wait I don't have cutlery I
do it's cool
should we start Oh should we stop we'll
start with the miso yeah go wrong with
miso soup Oh No yes it's like a drink on
the side anyway like why would you need
a drink if you got miso soup mmm okay
but then baby this man come at me I
don't want to eat the paper preferably
come on come down
where have you been all my life I love
it I love it
mmm if these are in England I'm gonna
find them anyway I'm gonna eat now